Okay. French Bob, girlies.
I got a French Bob just now.
Just. I'm still sitting in the salon parking lot.
This is what it looks like with a middle part.
I think it's so cute,
but when I put it to the side,
it's a little extra.
It's also so cute, like, tucked behind my ear.
I'm obsessed.
Here's. Here's what I think.
This is my honest opinion of this.
I've had really long hair, way past my butt.
I've also had like, shoulder,
shoulder length hair,
and then I've also had it, like here.
Honestly, at this point,
I think I've had like,
all hair links.
For me, it either has to be super short like this,
or it has to be long,
because the middle is not the vibe for me.
Um, but you guys,
what do you think looks best on me?
Do you think the middle part?
My husband loves the side part, though.
Or the side part,
because I think they're both so,
so cute. And I'm so excited.
I have a trip coming up next week,
and I feel like this.
This is the look.